normality in Britain seems far away
weeks ago face masks would have been
reserved for medical staff now they're
an increasingly common sight in public
this Kovach 19 survivor won't go outside
without one frankly it's better to be
alive than to not keep away from people
but having actually had the virus and
knowing how bad it is and obviously
speaking to people who've had friends
who've died then simple choice let's
keep the thing let's keep protected
these shoppers find comfort in wearing
them even if there are doubts over their
effectiveness when I sometimes wear one
sometimes I completely their loss to
know whether it's a good idea or not if
you could get your hands on one would
you wear a face I probably wouldn't
actually know I just feel that I don't
really need one the government is being
briefed on whether encouraging people to
wear face masks would allow for some
loosening of lockdown restrictions but
one expert says this shouldn't come at
the expense of those on the frontline
those key workers who cannot socially
distance the bus drivers the shopkeepers
the supermarket cashiers also need to
have protection because they are in
close proximity to other people too
however it's vital that this must not
mean that there's any reduction in
essential and vital supplies of
protective equipment including masks for
health and care workers social
distancing is working NHS England's
national medical director says the
number of deaths in hospitals is now
starting to decline
this is absolutely because we as a
British public have paid attention to
the social distancing guidance we have
been given and it's hoped the order of
50 million antibody testing kits will
give a clearer picture of who's already
had the virus researchers at Oxford
University are analyzing the blood of
people who have had the infection but
have now recovered they could cost as
little as 10 pounds and be available
over-the-counter but the World Health
Organization says there's no evidence
that people who
covered from covert 19 and have
antibodies are protected from a second
infection so without a vaccine when will
normal life resume life after lockdown
in the UK may be very different the
staggered reopening of businesses plus
physical distancing between deaths in
offices and even extra space between
passengers on flights are all being
discussed as the government discusses
the next phase of their response plans
may include quarantine impassive
entering the country social distancing
and hygiene on public transport will
also be closely monitored all part of
managing an outbreak whilst keeping the
country moving ash nihari nog Sky News